[Music]  rogers what in  heavens  [Music]  steve hey peggy now you owe me one  hold on a second she's friends with that  that hydra stomper  i think i'm friends with him too  yeah peace i love peace i'd be out of a  job with peace  do we know each other  time  reality reality  it's changeable  where you want to be  that's the question didn't it every  universe  is different each one  unique  slow down a little bit there's a few  people in the room that don't understand  not me i get it  who are you the name's captain carter  i am the watcher i observe all that  transpires here  but i do not cannot will not interfere  i guess i have to freestyle then  there bird a ravager never flies solo  i said never flies solo  ah is that some kind of catchphrase  you had me worried for a second  journey to face the unknown and ponder  the question  what if  [Music]  you